The definition of "jumping" in the dictionary is used by unimaginative filmmakers.
Cheap ways to scare the audience
According to many comments from my last video, many people tend to agree with this definition.
I also think that "jumping" has lost its former glory.
Not only because a lot of movies are full of them, but I think a lot of filmmakers don’t use them.
But I don’t agree with many people’s places. I think it’s a place to hope for “jumping”.
And people didn’t give enough surprises to surprise surprises.
So let's see what they can do
If you can't handle all the jumps
You are just a big coward
You are right, I am a coward.
In short, jumping is a sudden clip, usually accompanied by scary sounds.
To introduce this technique, let us look at an example that is not a horror movie.
I should. . . I really want to touch it again, the last time.
What makes this more than just a simple jump scare?
The important thing is that it is not only scary, but it highlights an important story point.
Appeared throughout the Lord of the Rings
Through a jump, we see how Bilbo was turned into a sin and horror creature by the Lord of the Rings.
There is no doubt that jumping is the best way to show the horrible things of the Lord of the Rings.
So now, in their remaining adventures, that jump has been entangled with us.
Remind us how dangerous it is to stare at the Lord of the Rings, and how powerful the Lord of the Rings is.
I think the shock is misunderstood because it can do more things.
Not just to scare us
Jumping should increase the sense of urgency by letting us doubt any safe moments
After being shocked, we are nervous
In each of the next long pauses or dark shadows,
There will be a deep suspense and warning because we will question everything we see.
This is where the director uses the jump to scare the mistake.
When used correctly, this technology will also make the quiet moments scary
I think it is in front of us
It may be anywhere! The fence is down and it can be worn in any area it likes.
A jump should be like real life:
Once you are scared, you will be scared for the rest of the night.
In the great movie "Witches", a very subtle and rare jump is used.
They are not terrible in themselves, but fast clips and changes in sound
Still adding to the overall suspense of the film
This technique is often misused
Not used in scenes with surface serenity and suspense
For example, Silent Hill: Revelation, almost everything is scared
Including toast
Ok, I take back what I just said.
You can use toast as an effective jump,
But it is building an excellent story.
Another person doesn’t know why it’s scary.
Take the ten most intimidating analyses of WatchMojo history:
"" One or two mammoth faces or huge noise
It’s a place that makes scars very scary."
This is a completely wrong jump analysis
The most important thing is not to scare itself, but to create a scary 30 seconds before the moment.
Create time to distinguish between good jump and cheap jump
Take the Sixth Sense as a simple example
The tent slowly opens from the upper left corner until the lower right corner, and the lens moves with it.
This move guides our eyes to the bottom right corner - jumping to wait for us
This jump does not have a quick clip, and there is no discreet and scary move.
This scene is scary because of the slow lens movement camp
Compare all the lazy jumps: the bad guys appear in the bathroom mirror
No time to build, it is an old routine
These guessy jumps are the reason why the scare has become notorious.
The best jump should be beyond our expectations, not as we expected
In "Hidden", this jump is unexpected, because we subconsciously expected
Terror will appear through flashback, not her story
Similarly in Jaws
The most horrible thing we guess is when he finds his teeth.
But there are more horrible things to happen later.
An excellent jump is very similar to magic: it is about the performance skills that attract the audience.
Let us use the lines in "Fatal Magic" to summarize this technique.
All magic consists of three parts or three actions
The first part is called "guarantee": the magician shows you the usual things.
a stack of cards, a bird, or a person
He shows you this object
Maybe he will ask you to check it out
To prove that it is an ordinary object
You must know
ordinary
But of course it is probably not
The second part is called "turning"
The magician holds the ordinary object
Did an unexpected thing
Now, you are thinking about where the secret is, but you can't find it.
Of course, because you are not really looking for
You don't really want to know
You want to be entertained
But you won’t applaud now, because it’s not enough to make something disappear.
You need to change it back
This is why all magic has a third action
The hardest part
We call it "reputation"
Let's face it right, it's usually bad to jump, but don't die.
Because when used correctly, they are also very powerful.
Don't be afraid, I won't end this video with a jump.
Or I will hhh
Thanks for watching